[Music]
spider-man fans are interesting and I
mean that in the literal sense it's not
code for bitter crazy or obsessive
actually interested when the first
spider-man movie came out people went
crazy this is it this is spider-man on
the big screen they totally got it right
and then when the second reboot came out
everyone said oh yeah that old
spider-man crap that's history this is
the one that gets it right this is the
one that finally nailed it and now we're
on the third reboot spider-man
homecoming and yep this is the one that
gets it right the others were crap this
is the one that totally nails it awesome
so we finally get spider-man as an
actual man oh no he's still a boy again
okay the others did that I guess it'll
be nice to see him hook up with Mary
Jane again oh she's not even revealed as
Mary Jane until the end I don't think
she's that confident Spitfire or really
cynical hates everything girl now
well this relationship with aging Aunt
May must blow that's that's different
well it'll be fun seeing him work as a
photographer for the Daily Bugle that's
not in this either well at least she
still has issues battling bullies who
are kind of bigger geeks than him we
know what as long as they get the core
the whole reason for him being
spider-man the death of his uncle been
not even mentioned I'm not even sure of
Uncle Ben exists in this universe Wow
that's kind of like taking away Batman's
parents it's honestly the reason he is
who he is but this is the spider-man
we've all been waiting for
I mean just look at that poster isn't
that exactly how we want to see the best
version of spider-man okay before you
bring down that anvil of hate on me keep
in mind I think this is a good movie I
think you could argue one of the more
entertaining if not the most
entertaining of the spider-man films Tom
Holland plays Peter Parker this time and
all movies based around him trying to be
the amazing spider-man while also trying
to have a normal social life and live up
to his hero Iron Man played again by
Robert Downey jr. but of course there's
trouble on the horizon as an evil
villain called the vulture played by
another Birdman Michael Keaton is trying
to get revenge for his job in life being
ruined at a lot of comedy twists and
turns and some really fun performances
and you get a very funny very enjoyable
Marvel movie yeah that's kind of the big
difference between this spider-man movie
and
the others the others were spider-man
films that just happened to be Marvel
this is a Marvel film that just happens
to be spider-man spider-man don't get me
wrong is supposed to be funny and at
times light-hearted but also supposed to
be big there's a reason he's one of the
most famous superheroes there is it
isn't just the powers it's the story
it's the character it's the conflict and
that's dabbled with here but there's
nothing really that grand or epic about
it the other spider-man's for all their
problems were big movies this I think
it's kind of on the level of ant-man I
loved bamm-bamm
but ant-man isn't spider-man spider-man
is spider-man and when I think
spider-man I think of him walking home
after letting his uncle down his head
hanging low thinking about with great
power comes great responsibility well I
got out of this was I really want to
make Tony Stark happy nailed it
now with all that said I know exactly
why they made these choices and honestly
they are the perfect choices to make
this is the third spider-man reboot in a
very short amount of time people are
sick of seeing him get bitten by the
spider people are sick of seeing uncle
Ben get shot they're sick of all these
repeated story elements that we've seen
a million times
Marvel very wisely takes a completely
different angle it does make it more
life it does make it more fun it does
make it more goofy you know not Sam
Raimi goofy but Marvel goofy the goofy
that we all have grown to love from a
business standpoint and an entertainment
standpoint this makes total sense to do
you can't do another big spider-man not
right now anyway you need something
smaller you need something cuter you
need something lighter they had to deal
with the limitations of the audience's
knowledge which is they've already seen
two spider-man series and more are
apparently on the way so yeah the
changes to this movie are actually very
clever I'll even go as far to say needed
to be done I like that they focus a lot
on the high schoolers and the New
Yorkers and their overall goofy attitude
Keaton is hands-down my favorite
spider-man villain both being kind of
funny but legitimately creepy at the
same time the action well now as epic as
the other films is still a lot of fun
and very smart I just don't get why
everyone says this is their big epic
spider-man movie
be really honest if you knew nothing
about spider-man and you just went into
this film completely blind would you say
this is one of the great superhero
movies would you say that was huge epic
I can see this lasting for years and
years I honestly can't but at the same
time compared to the other spider-man
movies there's kind of fewer flaws the
Sam Raimi films you can make fun of how
goofy and over-the-top and awkward they
are the Webb films you can argue how
overly complicated they are
comparatively this has the least
problems and I think that's why so many
people do see it as the best spider-man
film but because I do see spider-man as
a very big and even very important
character I really feel that size and
importance isn't represented here my
hope honestly is with future movies they
kind of work backwards maybe they can
show in flash bags Uncle Ben and
something that happened to homework
maybe go more into why spider-man does
what he does and him growing up and
becoming an actual man because here even
though I love seeing him interact with
Tony Stark that's not what should make
him want to be spider-man it's plain cuz
there's a scene where Tony Stark comes
in and takes the suit away and says you
had to figure out why you're doing what
you're doing and yeah I really agree
with that the movie sure thought about
why spider-man is spider-man the other
two films did this one I guess just
wants to be a fanboy of Stark and call
me crazy that's not what I think
spider-man is about I would like to see
more death I would like to see it go
darker I much rather have a spider-man
movie go all the way and take risk
because if you don't take risk
you're not gonna be big you're not gonna
be epic you're not gonna be daring yeah
the other movies have problems but took
chances and they seemed larger because
of it even though it didn't always work
out they knew they had to try something
big and daring with a character who's so
big and daring
so overall the spider-man homecoming is
a lot of fun and it is charming and it
is funny and I enjoyed it a great deal
but there's no way I can say this is the
definitive spider-man this is the one
that gets it right it's got the
light-hearted feel with a lot of charm
but not much more and spider-man is much
more but like I said spider-man fans
seem to love the hell out of it
Rango and moviegoers seem to love the
hell out of it so maybe I'm missing
something I still had a great time and
really recommend it
in terms of representing one of the
greatest superheroes who's been around
for years and years I think we still got
a long way to go before the spider boy
becomes a Spider Man